so the house judiciary committee has started
the process required to hold Donald Trump's
attorney, right?
Any General
William Barr in contempt for the first question
is what?
What does that mean?
What does, what does it mean to be held in
contempt?
In very simple terms, contempt is when somebody's
disobeys or ignores or disrespects the authority
of a duly empowered body.
Now, oftentimes we talk about being held in
contempt of court, but it also applies to
legislative bodies and is, in this particular
case, we're talking about Congress, contempt
of Congress, the House of Representatives.
If you obstruct the legal work of Congress,
which includes ignoring subpoenas, not providing
documents, this can all be considered contempt
of congress and that's exactly what Democrats
are alleging or will allege that William Barr
did.
He failed to comply with legal congressional
subpoenas when Congress requested the unredacted
Robert Mueller report and William Barr didn't
provide it.
Now this would just be step one, a of the
process of actually holding bar and contempt.
And I don't think that's a process that will
ever actually be followed through to its full
conclusion.
And I'll explain that in a moment.
But step one is for the committee to vote
on this, uh, tomorrow, Wednesday.
Now it's important to know that even though
bar released the redacted report, the unredacted
reports still has not been released.
And Chairman of the House Judiciary Committee,
Jerry Nadler says he'd consider postponing
tomorrow's vote on a contempt against bar
if bar gives them the full on redacted report.
No indication right now that that's actually
going to happen.
But the most interesting thing about this
is not the specifics of getting the unredacted
report.
I think they should have the unredacted report.
The most interesting thing about this is not
whether bar will actually be held in contempt
because I don't think he will.
And I'll tell you why in a second.
What's riveting about this is that this is,
uh, this contempt of Congress charge was one
of the three things in the articles of impeachment
against Richard Nixon back in 1974.
I told you last week that Trump 2019 is looking
more and more like Nixon 1974 and yesterday
on the show I did a story outlining how the
difference between 2019 and 1974 isn't that
what Nixon did is worse than what Trump has
done.
It's that Republicans in the 70s drew the
line at abuses of power of this level even
by people in their party.
Republicans in 2019, on the other hand don't
care about that.
They have no such line.
So that is why this is so interesting.
But to get back to the contempt itself, um,
contempt of Congress against a sitting attorney
general is unlikely to ever actually be carried
fully out because, uh, when think to what
Libertarians always talk about, they say the
government is an initiator of force because
eventually men with guns will come for you.
Doesn't sound like taxation is a, uh, some
kind of slavery under duress.
Well if you don't pay your taxes eventually
men with guns show up.
That actually is a relevant thing to think
about when it comes to contempt of Congress
against William Barr because if the house
committee votes to hold bar and contempt and
then the full house votes to hold bar in contempt
and everything else that has to follow from
that and happen to hold barring contempt does
happen at some point somebody has to physically
detain William Barr.
Is the house sergeant at arms going to physically
detained?
The Attorney General?
Very difficult to imagine that that's going
to happen is a court a court which is of course
part of the Justice Department that William
Barr himself overseas going to physically
detained.
William Barr.
Hard to imagine that that's going to happen.
So the actual holding in contempt of the attorney
general is more symbolic than anything.
But the reason why it matters is that this
is another one of these striking similarities
to Richard Nixon in 1974 and it is political
theater.
I mean it's political theater in the sense
that it's about what it means to think about
holding the attorney general in contempt rather
than actually trying to get the house sergeant
at arms to show up at the Justice Department
and say we're here for the attorney general
because that is very difficult to imagine
is going to happen.
But it also represents potentially the beginning
or the continuation of this exploding and
Trump's face.
We'll see how they vote Wednesday in the house
judiciary.
That's just step one.
And ultimately we'll see if the unredacted
molar report comes out, whether the full house
ends up taking this up and how this all impacts
the sort of particulars and logistics.
But once again, if we think about Trump 2019
Nixon, 1974 you look at those three articles
of impeachment that were filed against Nixon,
which ultimately didn't remove him because
Nixon saw the writing on the wall and resigned
in 1974.
The three things that, uh, were contained
in the articles of impeachment against Nixon
in [inaudible] 74 are all things that the
Mueller report provides evidence of Donald
Trump having done.
And once again, again, the general atmosphere
is contempt of Congress by an attorney general
gives us another reminder of Nixon, 1974 we'll
follow
it
for sure.